die heute schon gratuliert dem deutschen
gesundheitssystem zu einer teuren
breinig
[Musik]
vielen dank an das zdf bettpfannen
ballett und damit herzlich willkommen
meine damen und herren zum frühlingsfest
der geldverbrennung 344 milliarden für
mittelmaß wie geht das
ein neues deutsches wirtschaftswunder
und dafür wollen wir heute einfach mal
danke sagen dann gar an alle die
mithelfen diesen bargeld zu vernichten
so was ist immer eine teamleistung
krankenkassen ärzte und ja auch wir
patienten leisten unseren beitrag so lud
92 mal pro jahr geht der erwachsene
deutsche im schnitt zum arzt weit über
oecd-schnitt klar gehe gern zum arzt da
treffe ich freunde im wartezimmer
soll ich mir die vom spiegel kaufen oder
was deutschland ist spitzenreiter bei
operationen keiner verbaut mehr bei
presse oder künstliche hüften
ich selbst hab drei vorbildlich und wenn
ich schon höre wir machen zu viel mrt
gerade heute morgen habe ich bei einem
patienten in der röhre etwas ganz
furchtbares diagnostiziert hier schauen
sie mal an der hüfte eine aok karte
leider bösartig was hat so einer
überhaupt im mrt zu suchen
keine ahnung manchmal rutscht die
rheiner da rein
die faustregel lautet je kränker der
patient desto mehr kriegt die kasse
beispiel für eine echte depression gibt
es im jahr 1000 euro mehr als für eine
depressive verstimmung deswegen hatten
wir in deutschland in den letzten vier
jahren einen depression anstieg von
sagenhaften 60 prozent sieht zum
beispiel manchmal schlechte laune
na klar ich bin verheiratet chronisch
depressiv bitte er soll der scheiß
aggressive bipolarer störung
wahrscheinlich erektilen dysfunktion ist
wir haben viel zu viele krankenhäuser
und laut einer aktuellen studie der uni
bremen treffen ärzte ihre entscheidungen
immer mehr unter renditedruck und wenn
einer zu wenig op kandidaten besorgt
gibt es richtig ärger sie kriegen in der
regel 12 warnschüsse heißt mensch du
bist auch einer aus dem team nicht wahr
willst du nicht mitspielen mensch wir
müssen doch operieren was soll denn das
warum stellst du dich gegen uns es ist
so ein bisschen über einer straßen gang
und irgendwann kriegt man solche sätze
wie du ja wenn du nicht dazugehören
willst dann solltest du dir vielleicht
was anderes suchen ärzte gangs das sind
die allerhärtesten aber hallo
wenn wir kommen gegen die hells angels
auf die andere straßenseite ja
entschuldigung natürlich geht es um
rendite da bitten wir die patienten auch
einfach mal um verständnis
sie müssen sie mal klar machen oder
welchem druck die krankenhäuser
heutzutage stehen wenn sie jetzt als
klinik nur bezahlt werden wenn sie 50
knie operieren im jahr und haben 49
geschafft
dann brauchen sie 50 das heißt es ganz
sein dass dann die indikationsstellung
ein wenig lockerer werden
sie haben gehört was der mann gesagt hat
wir sind erst bei 49
ich bin also also ja natürlich gerne
link ist oder rechtes glied beide am 18
macht weiter so deutschland
[Musik]
[Applaus]